[MUSIC]
Hello there, thank you for coming.
And it's really a treat for you to
spend time with me during your reunion,
and I hope you're enjoying
yourselves as much as possible.
And we were just discussing snow
in other parts of the country.
So, if you're not from California,
also there's a weather treat.
So hopefully the weather will hold out for
you the whole time.
I'm going to talk a little bit about
the myths and the rituals of inclusion.
And to kick us off, I want to, so
how many of you have been on a Zoom or
a Teams call sometime the past two years?
Okay, so
I want you to pose about how you are in
your seat before the meeting starts.
Okay, now imagine the Zoom or
Team starts, show me what you do?
Anyone do that?
Right, now why is it that we have
expectations about how we are in our home?
And then how we are the minute
that camera comes on?
That's what I want to talk about.
There are myths, there are common
beliefs we have about what work is.
And those beliefs are myths,
shape how we behave.
And when unexamined, can actually be
a deterrent to creating a truly inclusive
workplace where people can thrive.
So I'm going to talk about that today, and
then I'm going to go into a little bit
about what GSB is doing about diversity,
equity, inclusion here.
So the definition of myth,
interestingly found
this in the dictionary,
is a widely held, but false belief.
I knew myths were something to debunk, but
when I looked it up in
the dictionary there it is.
Something that is false,
but wildly held as true.
And so when we look at
the workplace interestingly,
many of our myths or
expectations are widely held.
But when we look at the data underneath
them, they're actually false.
One of them is who is, a good worker?
And what does good work look like?
We have widely held beliefs.
In fact,
I speak to a lot of hiring managers,
how do you know the right candidate?
I can tell.
There's something about
the way they answer questions.
Again, what is that?
So one of the things we
know from research is that,
the ideal worker norm shapes who
we think is the best employee.
So the ideal worker norm was
developed really when there became
a separation of work and
life during industrialization.
Before that there really was no
separation of work and life,
that construct came
with industrialization.
So if you think about,
I don't know about you, but
I grew up reading books like
Little House in the prairie.
Anyone read that to your kids or
grow up reading those.
And if you recall,
the people who owned the stores, the kids,
Nellie Oleson,
would be playing in the store because
there was no work and
life it was integrated, or the farm.
Every one contributed to the success
of the farm, even little kids.
So this idea that there's work in
life is an idea that came through
industrialization.
And then to make sense of it,
we came up with expectations about what it
was to be a good and productive worker,
because we had never had office or
factory workers before.
And the net definition started to be that,
when you're at work,
you focus entirely on your job.
And home is something that
somebody else takes care of.
And a lot of the laws reinforce this
divide and this idea that anyone who's
distracted from work,
is not a good and productive worker.
Now unexamined,
these norms start to have things like
what we might call a motherhood penalty.
So research shows that if you have
a gap or you indicate your officer in
a parent teacher organization, your
resume is less likely to get called in.
Not because you're not
the perfect employee, but
because this myth about who a good and
productive employee is,
pervades today and affects how
we see talent in our workplaces.
Now, one myth I want us to work on
today is this idea of a meritocracy.
Many of our workplaces are designed
around striving to be a meritocracy.
So the idea of a meritocracy is
that everyone is evaluated for
the merit that they bring to the company,
the project, to the team.
And that every idea Is truly evaluated
based on the merit of that idea.
We hold that belief widely.
But research shows there's a lot of errors
that we make that prevent us from truly
seeing talent and ideas equally depending
on the composition of the person,
the identity of the person,
who's presenting the idea.
So, meritocracy is a belief,
it's a myth, that all people and
all ideas are evaluated based on merit.
Now, here's a really interesting finding.
Emilio Castillo and Steven Bernard,
Emilio got his PhD here at Stanford.
They did a research on a company,
about a 5000 person company.
And they went to the leaders and said,
what would you like to accomplish?
And they said we want to deliver
on this promise of meritocracy.
We believe a meritocracy is when we
very carefully evaluate performance.
And then when we give
out salary increases.
The performance correlates
to the salary increase.
So they worked with this organization,
had them do that, they were very proud.
By the end, they felt that they had truly
correlated performance, and pay increases.
And then the second phase was
the assignment of a merit bonus.
And as you know,
merit bonus is a one time bonus that's
given based on your performance.
So they asked the managers to
hand out merit bonuses, and
then they evaluated them, the researchers
did based on gender and race.
And what they discovered was that the
merit bonus was not linked to performance
rating.
But gender and race was more
predictive of how much you got.
And what they discovered is that if we
believe in this myth of meritocracy,
we are less likely to
scrutinize our behaviors.
So when managers work for what they
believe are a meritocratic organization,
they believe that they
are the ones who are meritocratic.
And what happens is,
they stop scrutinizing their behavior.
So if all of us have what
we call cognitive biases,
where we make errors based on
stereotypes about types of people,
if we all do that and we stop scrutinizing
because of the myth of meritocracy,
research shows that we are likely
to be more biased then if we have
concerns that we're not good,
and check our behaviors.
So how do you debunk
this idea of meritocracy?
One is there's a lot of research that
shows how these errors take place.
This one I really like it's in
the field of the legal scholars.
And they wanted to convince lawyers that
that bias existed even in the legal field.
And the lawyer said, well now,
our job is to find the truth.
We're really good at looking through
something and finding the truth.
There are biases in the legal field.
So what the researcher did was created
a legal brief and put errors in it.
Spelling, theoretical, grammatical errors.
Sent it to law partners with the request
to evaluate their third year law student.
And in it,
they simply wrote in the cover letter for
some that he is white and
some that he's African American.
And any lawyers in the house,
you don't have to admit it.
I've spoken to lawyers and they say,
who writes a brief doesn't matter.
A brief is a brief, it stands on its
own merit, yet what they discovered
is that when the lawyers thought that
Thomas Meyer was African American,
they found those mistakes that the
researchers had put in the legal brief.
Now notice that they didn't find them
regularly when they thought he was white.
Now why would that be?
The historical archetype of success
affects how we evaluate things.
In the past, there haven't been
a lot of black legal partners.
So despite the fact that for example,
Michelle Obama is a very well known
Black Legal partner, that hasn't affected
our stereotypes or how we see success.
So whoever doesn't match who we expect
to be there just gets more scrutiny.
And not only more scrutiny, but
then he black Thomas Meyer got
a rating of 3.2 and
we can't even believe he went to NYU.
And White Thomas Meyer has potential,
got a 4.1.
And this is where the myth of
meritocracy starts to fall apart.
We do these studies in countries all over,
right?
Europe, Asia, where they change
one thing in a resume and
they send it to actual hiring managers.
And they see how actual
hiring managers respond.
So we just talked about,
how race can affect evaluations.
In the UK what they did
was in some resumes,
said that the person had been a member of
a Gay Pride organization while in college,
that one had to send in more
resumes to get Collins.
The second one in Germany,
you can put a picture with your CV,
the exact same picture.
Sometimes they'd have a German name,
sometimes a Turkish name, and
sometimes Turkish with a head scarf.
And that was the least
likely to get called in.
So you could say ethnic national origin or
religious.
And then the last one was
the motherhood penalty I referred to.
So.
A resume says a person was officer
in a Parent Teacher Association.
It's called unless,
that resume is called unless.
Not only that, but
the candidate is rated less qualified,
less loyal, and offered a lower salary.
Now they did the same with two
men's resumes they put officer of
a parent teacher association at
the bottom of a man's resume.
It was called and more often rated,
higher more competent and more loyal.
So they call this the motherhood
penalty and the breadwinner bonus.
Now, I'm going to see how we're going to
do with our own automatic associations and
if you wouldn't mind calling out,
picture genius.
And then, who's willing to
tell me the name of a genius?
Is anybody, please?
>> Maradona.
>> Madame
>> Maradona?
The same.
Emmanuelle Miranda.
>> Lin Manuel.
>> Lin Manuel Miranda.
Anyone else?
Einstein, Claims
to have the highest IQ.
So somebody who has the highest
IQ would be a genius.
So we have artistic geniuses,
we have mathematical geniuses,
we have scientific geniuses.
In general, we tend to pick men as genius,
in general, right?
In general when I do this,
people in general say Einstein,
which you threw me a bone.
Thank you very much, appreciate it.
And what's hidden from view are often,
women, people of color who
are equally qualified in the exact
same fields, are hidden from view.
So what happens in our brains
is that when historical
archetypes are in words like genius,
it narrows our view.
And we ended up only seeing who
matches that historical archetype.
And even though there are a lot of other
folks there, we tend not to notice them.
If you saw when Forbes
launched its very first 100
most innovative leaders in America list,
there was a big Twitter storm because
the list had 99 men and one woman.
Now, when Forbes responded to this list,
they said,
well we did use a methodology,
but clearly it was flawed.
So if you're not seeking
to catch whether your
methodology has these errors in
it likely you are enacting it.
And that's how we try to debunk
these myths of the workplace.
By showing that these commonly held
beliefs are false, but widely held, and
we can debunk them with some
of the data that is done
here at the business
goal is being conducted.
Now in this study which was in 2019,
they worked with the group of scientists.
And they had them take that test to see if
they had bias against women in science and
they discovered that pretty
universally just like in the world,
people have bias that men are more
likely to be scientists than women.
That's not what differentiated them.
What differentiated the group was when
they asked why do you think there are so
few women in science?
And the ones that said, I don't know
science isn't sexist, we're empirical.
We're putting in one group.
And another group said, I don't know
either, but I know barriers exist.
And then they left them alone.
And two years later went and
looked at who they hired.
And it turns out the group that
acknowledged that barriers existed ended
up hiring more women.
And the ones that said,
I don't know science isn't sexist,
we're empirical ended up not hiring women.
So whether you believe these myths or
not, whether you seek to debunk them
can affect your behaviors in ways that
reinforce the myths or can debunk them and
come up with different outcomes.
So when I think about the difference,
it's not intention.
Scientists in both of
those groups had biases.
And in most cases people want
to pick the best person.
Very few people I talk to say, I hope I
pick the second best candidate, right?
But the difference or the actions
we take to block these dynamics,
these myths from affecting
our decision making.
And that's where I get to rituals,
so again I looked up the definition
of ritual it's an act or
series of acts regularly repeated.
So that's the thing about myths,
if we do something once,
it doesn't make the myth go away.
We have to regularly repeat actions
that block the myths from affecting
our decision making to have
any sort of different outcome.
And in a way, I think about
about honoring who people are.
I think about it as a ritual which
seems very much like a process.
This is actually trying to honor
the person I'm trying to evaluate,
really trying to see who they
are beyond these automatic responses.
So one way to debunk this
myth of the ideal worker,
to remember the ideal
worker is the myth that.
People who have work and
focus on work at work are more productive
than those who have home concerns.
One way to debunk the myth of the ideal
worker is by having regular check
ins at work.
Some really interesting work
done by Leslie Pirlo at
the Harvard Business School she was
studying the Boston Consulting Group.
And they were having issues because people
were feeling like they had no control
over their lives, and therefore this
work life, integration was failing.
So they instituted what they called
one day off predictably a week.
Now, if you're on a consulting project, it
meant even if you're in a different state,
you were off the project for
one evening a week.
It meant if you were buying tickets
to a show or you're trying to see
your kid's game that you knew that
night off was truly that night off.
Well, the teams end up
being more productive.
Not because that one night off was
necessarily rejuvenative although it was,
it increased retention.
But interestingly, because they had to
coordinate across how their personal lives
worked, they ended up communicating
even more strongly about their projects.
So some people argue we don't have time
for personal check ins we're about work.
Work is work and
personal life is personal.
But there's the chance that when you
integrate them through a simple check in
at the beginning of the meeting,
you can increase both work and
personal satisfaction.
By doing that regularly,
it can change the tone of work over time,
as Pirlo saw in
the Boston Consulting Group.
A ritual can also be as simple as agree
to criteria before you make a decision.
If you remember that brief where
the valuation of it shifted based
unconsciously on the stereotype of
the person evaluating it, well,
research shows that we
will shift the criteria.
So if we recall it was
the exact same legal brief, but
the criteria shifted in the valuation.
It turns out if you simply think
carefully about how you're going to
evaluate someone before you do,
you're less likely to shift it.
So for example, in the legal brief,
someone had said,
did you scrutinize for
spelling mistakes equally in both briefs?
Likely the ones who looked at the one
from white Thomas Meyer didn't check that
very well.
Sadly, this happened to me once at work,
where and we had candidates and
all of a sudden, the top candidate,
someone said, there are a lot of
spelling mistakes in their cover letter.
We didn't really notice it.
But I think someone who's going to be in
our role really needs to write well for
the public audience.
We really can't have spelling mistakes.
And so we thought, we should
probably discount that candidate.
What I didn't do and
I will regret forever is that I didn't say
did you equally check for
spelling mistakes in all the candidates?
Because if we had, I'm sure we
would have found a similar number.
Because we did it we ended up saying this,
okay,
we took the person off the qualified list.
So simply is saying if you're going
to hold someone accountable for
the way they're communicating or
the way they're writing.
Did you really check to see, that that was
equally scrutinized on every applicant?
Now, has anyone made a New Year's
resolution that didn't stick?
Kind of thing, yeah.
And in fact, a lot of people make
New Year's resolutions around eating like,
I don't know about you, but do you notice
I'm wearing this little top that's looser
on the bottom than it is up here.
This is what I call COVID clothing, right,
you got the nice snug part
where it doesn't count and
then a nice loose part where
the COVID effect has taken place.
So lots of people have given me advice
about what to do about COVID clothing.
And interestingly,
a lot of the things you're supposed
to not do make me want to do it more.
Have you ever tried that?
Like, I'm only going to drink wine on the
weekends, and then I have a really tough
meeting, like tonight I'll just have one
glass, not as a staff wineglass, right?
So there's ways that telling me not to do
something makes me want to do it more.
So it turns out in behavioral economics,
there's this idea of a nudge and
nudge doesn't tell you
not to do something.
But a nudge encourages you
to do the right thing.
It constrains your choices,
so you end up doing the right thing
without having to remember to.
Now, a good example,
is anyone not from the United States here?
Are you shocked about how
big our servings are?
It's like you could feed a family
off of one plate of food seriously.
I went to this one meal and
I can't believe I was eating it all and
in reflection it was the amount of food
that we usually buy for my family of four.
But I ended up eating it because it was
on this really beautiful plate, and
we were there.
And so it turns out, the plate size in
the United States has increased over time,
similarly to a lot of the ways
that we started to eat more.
So, if you simply eat off a smaller plate,
it's not telling me Laurie don't eat more.
It's just saying like how much
fits on this little plate.
So one way to help people with good
behavior is not to tell them don't
eat more.
It's really to figure out, you've heard
it, smaller plates, healthy sizes,
eat slowly, all those things.
Okay, so it turns out if you in your
work are making decisions about
people without some sort of scorecard,
likely you are making these shifts.
Even if your company has some
performance evaluation or
hiring platform if you as a leader
require that everyone do an input.
They're evaluations into a scorecard,
you're going to get less of the shifts and
evaluation.
If you in your agendas just regularly put
that check in at first it will be awkward.
But over time, you'll get more
accustomed to integrating work and
life and have less of a barrier.
Even during COVID a lot of women told
me there was understanding about them
having kids kind of running
through their Zoom screen.
And yet when we ask about promotions and
opportunities and
how they feel their advancement is going
they still feel like it was a constraint.
One thing a check in can do is help reduce
that myth that people with things going
on outside of work are less productive
than those who focus solely on work.
And then I love this idea
of changing the default.
So it turns out that unbeknownst to us,
we have defaults
about the way life works if you think
about for example parental leave,
often it's structured
around biological parents.
Which, in some organizations they
have to rewrite it to include, for
example, adoptive parents or
step parents, right?
So the default is a biological parent,
by shifting that it creates
more inclusion organizations.
Well, the way we talk also has a lot
of defaults, so if you say for
example, I want to welcome all
the couples and the same sex couples.
What I'm saying is the default
is a one man, one woman couple,
and everyone else is an exception.
So our words have ways of again
indicating who is more included
in our organizations and
who is an exception?
And if you've noticed around Stanford,
a lot of us will put our
pronouns on our zoom, IDs, or
when we work with undergrads,
it's often incorporated into
how they introduce each other.
Now, why is it important that
everyone shares their pronouns?
Well, it shifts the default, the myth
is that there's a default, and everyone
else is the exception but by shifting
the default we're debunking that myth.
So by sharing my pronouns, my name is
Laurie Mackenzie, I use she her pronouns.
I'm saying the default is that we all
might have different pronouns than
you expect, and therefore it's just
the way it is that we share them.
So in your workplaces as well, there
may be defaults that are unconsciously
being reinforced, where there's
something without a descriptor, and
everyone else gets a descriptor.
And the question is, could you catch those
and make it so that everyone is included?
Not a default and an exception.
Okay, now what have we done
here at the business school,
around some of these myths and some of the
ways to create a more inclusive campus?
And if you didn't know we've been
publishing a diversity equity inclusion
report for the past few years, this is
our third report which just came out.
And in all honesty,
we keep shifting when we publish it so
it's not like you would know it
comes out a certain time of year,
we rely on central Stanford data
about our representation and
we are kind of working out when that
comes in and then when we write a report.
But I wanted to share a little bit
with you about how we've tried
to be more inclusive in the work we do.
So one of the myths that
we as a university,
as people need to debunk is that well,
everyone can be their authentic self and
there's lots of data that shows that's
not true, equally for everybody.
So one thing Stanford University
did was they conducted
the largest scale culture
survey ever in our history,
President Tessier Lavigne launched it
after the murder of George Floyd and
said he wanted us to understand how race
affected how people felt here at Stanford.
Almost 15,000 people answered this survey,
it's the very first survey we've
ever conducted across students, staff and
faculty, exact same survey, because
what we wanted to understand was how is it
that people are experiencing the culture.
Is that myth true that everybody can
equally be their authentic selves?
This survey you can find it online they've
put all the results to be available
because transparency also helps debunk
myths giving everyone access to data.
What they discovered was that race and
sexual orientation,
sexual identity, plays a huge
role in how people feel that they
belong here on campus, so
what have we done about that?
We pilot what we call a small
wins approach to change,
it's hard to change the whole culture.
So we take bits of it, and
we try to evolve it in some of
the ways that I talked about today.
So one of the things we did was
last year we said we want all of
our resources developing new cases
to focus on leaders of color.
And it went from just 1% of our cases
being to adding 35 new cases last year.
And I heard one of the students
share in a course saying,
this was the first time
when I was in my class, and
there was a protagonist of color
talking about their startup.
Not talking solely about being
a protagonist of color or like
an entrepreneur of color, but being one
and sharing about their amazing startup.
So, it really can go a long way and
having our students feel like yes,
they truly can thrive regardless of
how they look or where they come from.
We've also thought about how we can
help our faculty create more inclusive
classroom experiences and this just ended
the student panel was just this week.
So we did a couple of things,
first two years ago,
we launched a training called,
sensitive topics in the classroom,
where we talked about how to manage
sensitive topics that come up through
current events or
case studies that could inadvertently or
comment that could inadvertently cause
someone to feel like they didn't belong.
And then this year what they did
was we went a step further, first,
we had a panel and invited faculty to
attend of three faculty who shared their
experiences of both creating an inclusive
classroom but also dealing with pushback
against their identities in
the classroom and what they did.
And then just this week, Wal Torres
who works in our admissions curated
a panel of force five students who shared
their experiences in the classroom
when it wasn't inclusive or shared
how amazing it is when professors did
certain things to have their
identities be welcome in the classroom.
So again, how do we as a business school,
as a leading business school,
create environments where everyone
can equally see that they thrive?
We had a conversation with staff
on Thursday with Brian Cooke
who works in our institutional research
and Ayodele Thomas who is the head for
staff diversity, equity inclusion for
all of Stanford.
Where we wanted to tell them we're
going to share these survey results
with you and go through them with you so
everyone understands.
We're not hiding the data, we're sharing
the data so that we can all think about
ways that we can reduce the barriers for
people feeling like they belong.
And lastly, we've been looking
at the curriculum we do,
I don't know if it has anyone
been to building momentum?
So it was originally designed for
women alums entrepreneurs
to help them succeed in
the ecosystem of entrepreneurship.
And then in 2021 pivoted it thinking,
well, we're online,
why don't we take advantage of that,
instead of being just for women.
The idea was to advance diversity and
to give access to the amazing curriculum
offered here at the business school
to anyone who was able to log on.
And as you can see, there were 355 people
who attended and there were requirements
for registering, it wasn't just if
you were interested in hearing.
And 62% of them ended up being non alums,
which was really great for
us to share our good work, and
50% of our attendees were either Black or
Latino, US based attendees, right.
So thinking about a curriculum,
a classroom experience, our staff,
trying to debunk the myths that
it's fine the way it is and
figuring out how we can be proactive and
creating more inclusion and
more to be proud of here
at the business school.
If you haven't read it,
it's on our website, if you just look for
a diversity equity inclusion report,
we have six priorities that we
work on here and we've been working on for
the past three years.
One to increase the diversity
of our Stanford community,
two to create an inclusive classroom and
learning experience,
create an inclusive and
welcome main campus community.
Support new research efforts, especially
around diversity, equity inclusion,
share our good ideas with the world as
with the conference I shared about.
And then we've integrated
our action plan for
racial equity into the core report
with the last priority which is
to address racial and
inequality in our community and society.
So while we still have a lot of work
left to go, we're going to keep
trying to debunk these myths and
install nudges and rituals so
that we can, not only for
ourselves the student experience.
But hopefully as that saying goes,
change lives, change the world,
change organizations, change the world
hopefully by debunking the myths we will
create more opportunities for people to
truly achieve their fullest potential.
[MUSIC]